[Music]
hey what is going on people another day
and another Biddy Oh see I'm not on a
project right now so I could go ahead
and create more content for you like I
said man if you haven't checked out that
patreon get on that patreon because you
know YouTube medium-duty monetizing all
my stuff because they don't like that
realness or maybe I just curse too much
I don't know it's funny when people
leave comments below and they go you
know what Damon there are young people
that watch you you're trying to inspire
this youth how dare you curse so much
man [ __ ] you [ __ ] not everybody gets
inspired the way that you get inspired
alright people think that you have to
inspire people in a certain way where I
grew up
everybody cursed and we all turned out
great you bitch-ass [ __ ] suck
the side of my left nut not the right
one you don't deserve that one you
stupid idiot
that one's reserved for the special
people your mom but anyways let's get
into the video today and I wanted to do
a positive video because dude check this
out holiday mother [ __ ] spirit homie
good deeds always make me so happy and I
don't know what it is I know that I'm
not that type of person to do some [ __ ]
like that because you know [ __ ]
strangers did you see how happy it was
my god that build my body with the Holy
Spirit I love watching videos when
people do nice [ __ ] like that it just
lights me up like a like a Christmas
blunder joy oh joy that's not happiness
is the same type of happiness I get when
I order chicken nuggets and then I get
like eight pieces instead of six I only
order six but I got two extra my fat ass
starts to Riverdance like a goddamn
anglo-saxon
that [ __ ] in the Bible it says to keep
your eyes and your spirit open because
the signs of God out there we just
choose not to see them amen well you
give me two extra chicken nuggets and
I'll see that you have risen from the
dead Lord hallelujah
it's weird cuz I can see God's miracles
before me but for some reason will not
get two chicken nuggets suddenly I start
speaking in tongue how would I say
matter how wonderful that chicken is I
buy you guys do have the Green Man it
feels good to do nice things for other
people you know what I'm saying and I
understand too because nowadays I think
because of YouTube and social media is
hard to see the the genuine effort and
people trying to do nice things in this
YouTube world right sometimes it almost
seems like the good deed is done not to
show people record it to say like hey
you should go out and do this too but
it's to kind of get people to compliment
them cuz what's a good deed if people
don't know I'm doing good things right
pieces of [ __ ] it's like when you buy a
drink and you're supposed to tip in the
tip jar you kind of just wait for that
person that comes with a see you putting
the money in there you don't say like
this Oh buck thank you I'm gonna make
your drink now wait but before you do
watch me put this five dollar bill into
this [ __ ] cup cuz I'm a good
person I only say this cuz I do this all
the time
they have to know that I didn't put just
a dollar in there like everybody else I
put five dollars because I know you got
like six kids and you haven't fed yet
but you guys remember that right when my
charity was like the the trend on
YouTube but they would do things in such
a ridiculous way in a fashion that it
wouldn't even highlight the good deed it
was highlighting themselves it got to a
point where people were doing these fake
videos like it would be on some [ __ ]
like what's up guys today it's your boy
Zach money balls and I'm gonna feed the
whole was today cuz it's all about being
champ know you're a good person man it's
not about me it's not about me I'm
[ __ ] awesome yeah you might as well
just suck your own dick at that point my
name there could be a lot this video is
that is so Ken it's just like this nest
cam that they leave in front for
security but it caught this guy enjoying
the [ __ ] out of this small beautiful
lovely deed oh that may be fissile god
this [ __ ] felt so good he had to
get the gangster out of him son you
start to see walking back to the truck
[Music]
now we could get into a whole
philosophical discussion about what it
truly means to give without expecting
anything in return but this is a comedy
channel you [ __ ] it's not it's not it's
not a philosophy channel so go talk
about that out of [ __ ] because I get it
some people say that when you give out
of the goodness of your heart it's
really hard to see because we sometimes
we do that because we want to feel good
about ourselves too and and that is the
give-and-take of it right but I still
think to a certain extent there's some
purity in it and when I see a video like
this especially during the holidays it
lights me up it's the holidays
[ __ ] if you guys want to see
more videos send some more videos my way
and let's talk about it oh by the way
this thursday joe and i will be talking
about the brother nature situation and a
few other hot topics because i know you
guys are asking probably why we're not
doing a video about it on this one but I
gotta get Joe on that one so check it
out on Thursday on the podcast we go
talking about brother nature and the the
h3h3 scandal with the whole kpop
situation ooh
well that's it for this video guys I'll
see you all next time support on the
patreon I love you very much and let's
list list list
let's open mouth kiss each other
sometimes huh